hi Rick how are you dan I'm doing great
my question is how are you doing how are
you handling that big number that's on
your birth certificate these days I'm up
there right there with you well I'm I'm
in denial I'm just flat-out lying about
my age these days i'm not actually
admitted it yet you have any advice for
me about it drink you know that could
you could you throw your age right now
oh yeah yeah absolutely whatever 75
could you throw that uh yeah yeah I
think I could I mean you know in spring
training every year I throw a lot of
bragging practice with the cups and you
know just to kind of stay ready because
you know Mark Harmon we have that
benefit baseball game down in Oklahoma
City and you know I don't get a whole
lot of help from he know the guys that
he grew up with so i think one year i
got the win to hold and to save no yeah
i think i think i could do 70 I don't
know about 75 that that's that's a good
question are you doing spectacular
everything's great I don't I don't get
to see you anymore um World Series
occasionally but you need to you need to
come around we're still we're still
having a good time says he was here in
Kansas City a couple of weeks ago we got
Rascal Flatts tonight we're going to go
looking for love tomorrow with Johnny
Lee so come see us how is Mark Grace
dunes no Rick that's what I want to know
you know that's one of my favorite
stories dan I think it's usually the
first story I tell about you was I think
we were roasting him or something or
maybe he retired and you flew in that
morning and caught a red-eye back out
that night just to to be a part of that
that's uh that's something that well
that's just a type of friend that you
you know he you know he tried that
marriage thing Danny wouldn't he was he
wasn't very good at
that you know he he he is he is a great
father and I don't think that surprises
any of us but he's terrific at that and
you know that that marriage thing didn't
work out real well in the story I heard
and I don't know as to be true because I
don't think it's fair for me to ask but
I i guess at one point he and tiny were
sitting having coffee and Gracie walked
in and he NE handed her like a file and
she says what's that and he says well
just take a look at it well he did found
some photos or something she was doing
some things she shouldn't have done and
she goes hold on a second and she goes
into the bedroom and comes out with a
file it was like 10 times and that's
what they did they just laughed about it
they said you know take the marriage is
oval are we gonna do we got these two
boys so I think Gracie's doing great you
know that assistant hitting coach kind
of thing yeah can he but here's a guy
who didn't use batting gloves like grace
got to the plate he was a no-nonsense
guy can you teach that to these kids
nowadays you know what there's there's
there's a couple of those that are still
around but you know the thing is to me
it's stupid because you know people like
Nike you're gonna pay you you know a
hundred thousand dollars to wear those
batting gloves I I don't care if you
like it or not there's a lot of things
you can do with that kind of money he's
Rick Sutcliffe with a mothership former
shy young winner a couple things here
did did you want steal home back in any
was that like late 80s you stole home
and again it would be easy for you to
forget damn because it happened so quick
I mean it yeah I did I I think I'm the
last pitcher to have stole home for 44
in my career I mean that it shouldn't
have come as a surprise but it was on
this day though Rick in 1988 was it
really yeah I know I know Kevin gross
was on the mound and it what happened
was I think there were there were two
outs or something and Mitch Webster was
at first base i'm at third he takes off
and kevin gross did that 3rd to 1st move
and Mitch gets caught in a rundown and
he's going to be out so I just take off
I mean I'm gonna I'm gonna be out by 50
feet but I
Ricky Jordan arrived I knew that he was
the first base was I knew he couldn't
throw I knew he's terrible so I thought
what the heck oh you know if not he
throws it like halfway up on the screen
I'd have been out by 42 feet and yet I
can't credit I know people look at me
you know even when I played you look at
me and you don't you just don't think
stolen base now you didn't look at that
body no no did you uh were you still
pitching when Jordan was playing
baseball uh no no no we were broadcast
in there did you have Dave Stewart a
bunch of guys went you know and worked
out with him and all of that I'm the one
I get credit for taking Garth Brooks to
spring training yeah but Gauri's got a
base hit didn't he he did he got a base
hit and I think it was an RBI off of
jamie moyer you know and God knows the
story I mean I hope you didn't get mad
at me but you know when he would play I
would talk to the opposing pitcher and I
literally because of being on you know
baseball tonight and I would threaten
him I you know if you anything over 85
and I will crush you the rest of your
playing career every chance I get anyway
I didn't have to tell Jamie that so just
his hitting his RBI those those are all
legit I mean he he absolutely earned
that and as you know was just you know
he was just a pleasure to be around the
White Sox have played better as of late
although losing last night but is Chris
Sale more likely or less likely now to
be traded he's not going anywhere Dan I
mean that's you know when you look at if
you were to start a franchise right now
and you could have anybody you wanted
this guy would probably be in the top
ten you can't do that you've gotta you
gotta mend that sense and I was talking
about it you know during this past week
did a couple of the games you know in
that crosstown classic that when when
they were really good early in a year I
think they were 17 and eight or
something in April and had like a
six-game lead in May the reason they did
it was because their pitching was so
good and with them getting you know read
on back and and and and shields stolen
well now they've got a chance to with
this rotation to get back
to playing the type of baseball they did
earlier so I mean if I'm a white sauce
scene right now I turn the page on what
happened there was sale walking out and
I looked at a couple of pieces i look to
maybe add a you know a bat in the middle
that liner I hope that Abreu gets back
on track he's he's not swinging the bat
like he did the last couple of years but
you know he still feel like he's going
to do that the Cubs World Series or bust
oh yeah yeah there's there's there's no
question when you know Theo Epstein came
when he left the Red Sox to to come to
the north side of Chicago that was the
only the only goal that he had right
there and when you know people look at
what happened last year and how you know
the first three years of his tenure they
were in last place they had Joe Maddon
this is the then you and I you know you
know better than I do this is what do
did in Boston this is what Joe Maddon
did in Tampa these guys are just
continuing to do what you know they've
already done if not the Cubs then who I
like the Texas Rangers a lot and I'll
tell you why I you know the one thing
that John Daniels and Theo Epstein have
in common is they're both tremendous
draft and develop type guys the reason
that the Cole Hamels went to Texas was
because the Texas Rangers had what the
Philadelphia Phillies wanted the same
thing is true for Chapman Chapman could
have gone anywhere and and and Brian
Cashman had a chance to look at every
contending organization and the players
that he wanted were in the cub system
that's what you know that's what those
guys have in common and when you look at
general managers right now in the next
couple of days are going to determine a
lot of the teams that make the playoffs
and don't if you don't agree with me you
know and all you got to do is look at
the World Series last year I'm cesta
this was a big big part of that and of
course Zobrist and and and Cueto were a
big part for Kansas City so what happens
in the next couple of days are going to
be key and a lot of the reason why
something happens is the type of you
know minor league system that you put
together did you ever go drinking with
Harry Caray oh yeah yeah yeah we we we
we called it you could tell the look
face it had done it the next day because
we we called it the Harry Caray flu you
know you go out within the night before
your you're going to wake up the next
day just feeling like crap I mean it's a
lot like hanging with you buddy yeah
absolutely absolutely we had a question
the other day would you rather have
Roger Clemens career or Mariano Rivera's
career everything that is involved with
those careers without a doubt Mariano
Rivera yeah that's what I said you know
I believe everything that he did I don't
I don't believe everything that is on
the back of Roger Clemens baseball card
but but but he we see him in bonds they
seem to be intertwined here of moving up
the voting for the Hall of Fame do you
think that they ever get in I I think
Barry does for sure and I you know Dan I
everybody I think I faced him 70 times
or something and the most advanced off
of anybody that he didn't hit a home run
off of and but I face the guy that was
you know stealing 50 bases a year not
the guy that was hitting 50 home runs I
I thought he would have I thought he was
a surefire Hall of Famer before you know
he started hitting 50 60 and 70 home
runs I thought he was that guy just my
personal opinion I didn't feel like
roger was until Roger got up there to
Toronto and my problem is this though
Rick are you a Hall of Famer if at any
point in your career you you use
performance-enhancing drugs I say no Dan
and I'll tell you why I I questioned
myself a lot I knew back when I tore my
hamstring an 85 I knew there were some
things I could do and the only thing
that kept me from doing it was the fact
that the doctors told me it was illegal
by law and they didn't know enough about
it looking back on as you know eight
years ago excuse me i was diagnosed with
colon cancer and the first question my
surgeon asked me was you know if you
ever taking steroids and I went oh so
we're good and I said well why well
because you know it could have
accelerated the growth of the cancer
that was in me so as I look back on that
I mean I'm thrilled that I didn't
also in a lot of ways think that I might
have treated the Cubs organization by
not doing it a lot of people were a lot
of people knew and now as we look back
on it we know we know the advantages
that came from it you know you sada the
United States anti-doping agency when
they spoke to all of us at ESPN a they
talked about your muscle growth your
view you know your recovery time and
then they talked about your vision you
know I said well how can that help a
hitter well with most people your vision
when you're on allow that stuff they
were saying your visions doubled so
everything that you need to be a better
hitter we know doubled in a good way
doubled in a good way yeah yeah if i
gave you a mulligan back in 1985 would
you take steroids well not knowing that
i was going to come down with cancer um
you know let's say you doing let's say
let's say you you weren't going to be
diagnosed but now you could have a
do-over I you know what note then I
wouldn't and I'll tell you why because
my daughter years ago as i said this set
up in a banquet at the cubs convention
my daughter said the one thing I know
dad you sleep good at night don't you
and I do I do there's there was nothing
there I just when I the guy I think of
Dan is a good buddy of ours is Wally
Joyner yeah Wally Joyner was an all-star
i think it was in 1986 his rookie year
he was voted in Mali wearing it wally
world yeah he never got to go back again
and a lot of it had to do with you know
the names McGuire and Tom marrow and you
know guys like that that we're going in
front of him you know that that you know
as we look back on it now I mean they
were doing some things that while he
didn't do hey did you ever see the the
game show that what was it called it's a
family feud did you ever see the game
show that Wally and I were on with that
no didn't I oh you got to take a gander
at it's on the game show channel I mean
it's run every now and then it is wally
world he's with the angels were in la
were filming this I mean he's the most
popular guy you know and in the city
well anyway Ozzie Smith and Dzhokhar we
all do it so anyway Joe Carter goes we
win the first round against the umpires
it would
real hard obviously we know doing that
but Joe cart while he goes into the
soundproof booth and Joe Carter's does
really well we get a lot of points and
the first question when wallet comes out
crowd going crazy his wife Leslie and
their four daughters right in the front
row and the first question as to wally
was out of 100 and survey then you know
who knows who these 100 men are what is
the most desirable age for a woman and
while he goes 21 well this obnoxious
horn goes off and I mean it everybody
just kind of scared what well Joe Carter
had used that number had already been
used while they try again well Walley in
a total panic goes 16 oh I'm gonna look
at it I could not even ask another
question I mean he takes a knee Leslie
grabs the four girls they walk out I'm
going to add a poly brought bringing up
during the commercial break I gotta run
here Rick will be watching on Sunday
night always great to catch up with you
bud then it's so good but he's you're
the best the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience